so judge it's determined to be a
homicide and there's only one person of
interest right is that basically it yeah
he's a person of interest they're not
calling him a suspect i suspect there
are reasons they're not calling him a
suspect why why were there certain
things certain legal obligations that
kick in once you're a suspect once
you're labeled a suspect and i think the
police are not under a you know any kind
of requirement that they call him a
suspect now here's the issue in this
case if the manner of death is a
homicide we don't know the cause of
death was she hit with blunt force
trauma was there a strangulation i'm
kind of inclined to think there was
something that was you know very
physical because they were physical but
my biggest concern is something that i
said last week and that is that the cops
in utah did not make an arrest and the
dispatcher said that there was a caller
saying that he was hitting her in
addition to that we've got another
witness who says he was hitting her and
i pulled up the utah statute which is
like most statutes across the country
and i i know this because i've been
doing domestic violence prosecutions
since 1978 okay there is something
called mandatory arrest the cops are
mandated to determine who the primary
aggressor is not the last person to hit
but who's a primary aggressor
he we know from the scene last week that
he was holding her face and the police
say oh he was holding her face to stop
her from hitting him to stop him from
hitting her he wasn't letting her in the
car he she was chasing the car he had
her phone he wouldn't give her the phone
we're talking jealousy control all the
indicia of domestic violence and they
tell them to separate and they talk
about mental health no this is domestic
violence you make an arrest you decide
who's the aggressor and under utah law
you arrest one of them and if that were
the case this would not be happening wow
what do you think carollo is well i
think i think a lot of things i think
the police work certainly uh deserves
scrutiny harsh scrutiny in in light of
what we know about what they did and did
not do
a couple of other points though
men think they're so slick they think
that uh you know it never happened
before uh they can they can put one over
on the authorities they can uh you know
uh make the team you know i don't know
what happened to her my goodness what
happened the man always did it i mean
that's that's my presumption my working
presumption is the guy did it
start your investigation
right there
the other thing is
social media is a lie
when you see social media instagram all
these other things the kids are into
everybody's skinny everybody's beautiful
everybody's in love everybody's dancing
and skipping and and you envy them and
you never envy anybody
everyone's got situations in their life
for sure live your life
don't look at these pretty people and
say i want to be like them
he was hardly pretty though
john so listen i agree with the judge
law enforcement
left something to be desired and how
they handled this case but i just tell
you as a former prosecutor
we also had a mandatory arrest statute
in wisconsin but oftentimes the cops and
i don't want to defend them but they
come across these situations all the
time and women oftentimes will we can't
say look at the seriousness of what the
altercation was i'm just telling you the
perspective of law enforcement the the
how serious was the altercation and and
and they don't make the arrest that's
what happens but hold
but i want to look at the facts i mean
we all suspect we all have the right
suspect i think brian landry but there's
this consciousness of guilt what did he
do after the crime right so he flees the
scene
he goes back to florida uh without his
fiancee doesn't tell anybody where she
is doesn't talk to the parents doesn't
talk to the cops and lo and behold
he vacates his parents house and he
can't be found though everything he's
done shows a consciousness of guilt that
he was the one who caused the homicide
but to your point judge the aggressor is
the one who should be locked up instead
of just
separating them for the night he should
have been arrested because in this and
then her parents would have known that
something would have known and there
would be a different situation now i
started the first domestic violence unit
in the nation in 1978 okay it was a
department of justice it was a pilot
program okay you're seven then okay well
i'm old okay so here's here's the thing
we know
that if the police can't make an arrest
and you let them go on their merry way
they end up dead or seriously injured
because domestic violence increases in
intensity frequency and severity and the
guy thinks he's got it all over
everybody as time goes on you also know
this i know but what will happen is the
woman will all of a sudden say no no i
was the guilty party i was the aggressor
you know what
happened
that wasn't the case if she has the
right support if she has a support
system where she's got shelter and she's
got opportunities to defend herself then
cops don't say hey you know she liked it
let her happen
and she could still be alive today had
law enforcement done what they were
supposed to she would probably still be
alive you're right right did she call
her mom what did the parents know what
did the guy's parents know when he went
home did he speak to his parents oh if
they if you're a kid here's the question
right
your your
son is suspected of something
did he talk to his parents
would you if you were a parent then
called the authorities what would you do
i think there's a question of whether he
ever actually went to florida oh of
course um so i and you have this this
crazy situation oh go ahead do you think
the parents could be charged sure i mean
i'm not a lawyer don't know but they
helped him if they helped him escape if
they created a detour and said hey he's
he went this way waiting in a bed
they're not talking to the authorities
but how did his vehicle get there then
because because the white van got better
that's a great question how did it get
there and remember the sister goes on
good morning america last week and she
says
i haven't been able to talk to i haven't
seen him and i haven't been able to talk
to him but she lives right there but she
can't go in the house and see her
brother
i don't think he was ever there she used
a very interesting word
she said you know there must have been a
misunderstanding
and to me i just kind of spun around a
few times and i said she knows that
something happened right she didn't make
that up well i just hope that he had the
good the good taste to take his own life
see i would say i think the family
deserves justice and then he should be
held yeah suicide's a cowardly way out
for the crime you hate a woman you're a
coward